cette javeleuse n'avait plus fauché les
blés depuis 1850 ce matin après quelques
réglages elle est parfaitement en marche
et comme à l'époque les hommes et les
chevaux travaillaient dans les champs
pendant la moisson l'association commune
libre de saint-biss tient à faire
connaître la récolte du blé patrimoine
culturel de la bosse une javeleuse c'est
vraiment l'ancêtre l'ancêtre des
battag des coupes donc à partir de là le
même procédé la barre de coupe existe
maintenant sur le le matériel que vous
allez voir là avec tiré par un cheval et
que vous retrouvez dans les mêmes
conditions mais évidemment à un stade
beaucoup plus important dans les
nouvelles moissonneuses batteuses chaque
année une partie d'un champ est réservé
par un agriculteur au Coudré pour
travailler à l'ancienne l'association
fait alors participer des bénévoles et
met ainsi en avant la moissonneuse la
faucheuse liant le blé qui date de 1914
la bosse est le grenier à blé de la
France et quelques paysans se souvienent
encore des gestes je suis en train de
lier une javelle et normalement on prend
la ficelle mais on on devait faire ça
avec des liens on nouit la paille comme
ça et avec les deux extrémités là
naturellement c'est trop court c'est du
blé fait du segle fait de la grande
paille et on on parce que avant la
ficelle c'était avec ça qu'on qu'on liit
les gerbes le blé récolté sera battu en
septembre pendant la fête des vendanges
l'occasion de découvrir ou redécouvrir
les traditions populaires et les
pratiques agricoles du début du 20e
siècle en bosse